When you think of a sculpture,
you probably imagine one of these.
Would you ever imagine something that
can fit in the eye of a needle?
Huh?
Meet Willard Wigan.
I'm Dr Willard Wigan MBE.
I make the smallest sculptures in the world.
I've made fourteen camels in the eye of a needle...
The Queen's carriage
And I've made one of the Queen herself
Mount Rushmore
Sunseeker Yacht
Evolution of man
Marie-Antoinette
Little Red Riding Hood
Einstein, and more.
I'd be here forever trying to tell you.
I've done that many you know.
It all began with an ant's nest.
I thought the ants were homeless,so I started making them tables and chairs.
I started picking up little fragments of splintersand slicing them and constructing and buildinglittle houses.
I'm autistic and in school they
didn't really care.
I call it a learning difference - I just learn different to anybody else.
I startedexperimenting to see how small I could really go.
How do you make something so beautiful?
WhenI'm working on a microscopic level, I have to work between my heartbeat
because if I don't, the pulsein my finger will cause problems.
But the tools are very important because they all vary. There's alldifferent types of tools.
The cutting is the most important thing.
Slicing and twisting and bendingand manipulating.
I use a little broken shard of diamond- smashed- and it's like a little splinter. It looks like a stone age splint being microscopic.
So it's like my pulse is a little jackhammerchiselling away until I get the shape I want.
I normally pluck an eyelash out from the corner ofmy eye
then I attach it to a little cocktail stick
and then I paint with it.
I work on five ata time.
If I work on one it'll drive me mad.
[Music]
I have two world records.
The smallest sculpturesever made by human hands
not no machine no nanotechnology.
But these micro sculptures don't
always go to plan.
I remember once I was making a sculpture of Alice in Wonderland.
After I'dmade the Mad Hatter and I made the teapot, I made Alice separately.
And I was lifting her, put
her into the needle, and my mobile phone went off.
I went like this.
Who's that?
And I inhaled Alice. It just went. She's in my cavity somewhere.
Gone.
The work that I do, it doesn't belong to
me.
I like other people seeing it. I like to sitthere and watch them.
Some people burst intotears when they see my work, you know, and that brings it home to me what I've done.
The time thatI've put in has been worth it.
So what next for Willard?
I know he's stuck in the needle, yeah,
that's a good one.
I'm gonna do that you know.